اهلا بكم هنالك شيء تغير او انتهى في تونس
هل حقا هو سعيها للتغيير ام منظومه حزبيه
تم ارتجالها على عجل هل ما تعيشه هو نهايه
ديمقراطيه الحقوقيين ام ولاده ديمقراطيه
كل المجتمع ما دور البرلمان الجديد في هذا
ما اولوياته وكيف يرى السجال الداخلي
ومواقف اصدقاء تونس مما تعيشه اليوم اتحدث
بشان كل هذا لرئيس البرلمان التونسي
الجديد العميد ابراهيم بودر باله احييكم
اينما كنتم من العربيه انا منتهى الرمحي
وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
هنالك سؤال ما زالت تونس تبحث له عن جواب
منذ نحو عامين هل قرارات الرئيس قيس سعيد
لاستثنائيه التي اتخذها في الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو 2021
كانت نقوصا عن الديمقراطيه ام اصلاحا
لمسارها ما تشهده تونس يشبه او مرتبط
بمعارك وسجال تجري ايضا في الكونجرس وفي
اوروبا فبعد اختيار الايطاليين جورجا
ميلوني رئيسه لوزرائهم توعدتهم رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسولا فانديرلين بان
لدى الاتحاد ما قالت انها ادوات للتعامل
مع روما اذا اتبع شعبها طريق المجر
وبولندا وهما دولتان اخريان تحدثا اجماع
النخبه حول معنى الديمقراطيه
هل الديمقراطيه هي الاراده الفعليه
الحقيقيه للشعب ام ان الديمقراطيه هي
مجموعه سياسات مقاييسها تتفق عليها نخبه
بعيده عن الشعب ولكن عبر توافق عابر
للاوطان مثل ما تدعمه
مؤخرا تساءلت واشنطن بوست بنبره عسكريه عن
الاسباب التي ادت الى فشل الديمقراطيين في
جعل عام 2022
مخصصا لهزم كل من يهدد الديمقراطيه في كل
مكان
واركانها ديانه جديده صالحه لكل زمان
ومكان
بمقاييس مقدسه ومثل النخب الغربيه اعادت
النخبه السياسيه في تونس تعريف معنى
الديمقراطيه بدلا من معناها الحقيقي
والاصلي اي حكم الشعب مثل ما عرفتها اثينا
حولتها الى حكم النخب الحقوقيه لا صاحبه
الكفاءه وحتى حركه النهضه فهي جماعه اقرب
للدينيه لا مشروع سياسي وطني لها اما بقيه
الاحزاب التي احتل ممثلها البرلمان وصار
لزعمائها مكان في الحياه العامه لم تكن
سوى تجمعات تم ارتجالها لم تنتج في كل
الاحوال حياه سياسيه سليمه لذلك يدافع
انصار الرئيس بان تونس لا تحتاج لاحزاب
نخب بعد فشلها في العقد الاخير وهو ما
ترفضه اوساط اخرى من المجتمع ترى ان لا
بديل عن الاحزاب في اداره شؤون الافراد
وفي الاثناء تبدو تظاهرات الاحزاب وكانها
قليله الدعم من الداخل ما يزيد من السجال
حول قدرتها على تطبيق ديمقراطيه صالحه
لحياه عمور التونسيين لا فقط لحياه النخب
اليوم استضيف سعاده السيد ابراهيم بود
رباله رئيس البرلمان التونسي الجديد
ليحدثنا عن كل ما سبق
ولد ابراهيم بودرباله عام
1952 وهو احد ابرز وجوه قطاع المحاماه منذ
عام 1977 تولى رئاسه الهيئه الوطنيه
للمحامين لعده سنوات وهو من مؤسسي الحزب
الديمقراطي الوحدوي زمن الرئيس الاسبق زين
العابدين بن علي ترافع ابو دربال طوعا في
عده قضايا ضد النقابات ومعارضين يساريين
واسلاميين وكان عضوا في هيئه تحقيق اهداف
الثوره عام 2011 وهو معروف بحياده الشديد
مع جميع الاحزاب والمنظمات كما انه مدافع
شرس عن عدم تسييس المنظمات النقابيه
والاهليه وعن استقلال القضاء والمحاماه عن
الاحزاب
الايديولوجيه سعاده ابراهيم بودرباله رئيس
البرلمان التونسي هو ضيفي في هذه الحلقه
في البعد الاخر اهلا بك معنا تقريبا ثلاثه
شهور مضت على بدء اعم ال البرلمان الجديد
الذي تتراسونه كيف بتقيم لي هذه الفتره
حتى الان
احنا تسلمنا المهام يوم 13 مارس الفرد
وشارعنا في عداد النظام الداخلي ثم تركيز
هياكل المجلس من مكتب مجلس واللجان والان
شارعنا في دراسه القوانين وبالتالي يعني
يعتبر تركيز الهياكل في وقت قياسي
وبدايه من هذا الاسبوع سوف نشرع حنا عده
قوانين على اللجان ذات العلاقه وسوف يجتمع
المجلس في جلسه هذا الاسبوع لدراسه احد
احد المشاريع القوانين وبالتالي يعني سير
المجلس
بصوره عاديه
انه بعد
تنصيب المجلس عاده الصلاحيات التشريعيه
للبرلمان بس مع ذلك الصوره العامه اللي
بتنطبع لدى اطراف خارجيه واحيانا لدى
اطراف داخليه انه الجانب التشريعي ما زال
بيد رئيس البلاد هل هي مغالطه ام انه ما
زالت تونس تعيش تحت الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
هل البرلمان هو من من بيده الجانب
التشريعي ام انه مازال بيد الرئيس
اكيد هي مغالطه باعتبار ان صلاحيه
التشريعيه تحولت الى البرلمان منذ يوم 13
مارس
ومنذ يوم 13 مارس لم يصدر اي مرسوم عن
رئيس الجمهوريه
انتظرنا طوال هذه المده
وحاله السيد رئيس الجمهوريه مشاريع
القوانين على المجلس ونحن الان على تم
الاستعداد
لدراستها وحالتها على الجلسه العامه
للتصديق عليها
شو اللي ممكن انه نعتبره انجاز مهم قام به
المجلس حتى اليوم صاير فتره قصيره ولكن
كثر يترقبون ما الذي يمكن ان ينتج عن من
قرارات عن هذا البرلمان
هو اكبر تحدي لهذا المجلس هو استرداد ثقه
الشعب في العمل البرلماني لانه لا يخفى
على عليكم وان اعمال البرلمان الفارط نظرا
للاحداث التي مرت به جعل العمل البرلماني
يعني
يكون محل صوره سلبيه لدى المواطن التونسي
وبالتالي لنها تحدي هام هو ارجاع يعني
المصداقيه للعمل البرلماني
ونعتقد اننا يعني الان سائرون في الطريق
الصحيح وبالتالي اهم انجاز هو انه بعد
يعني استقرار المسار السياسي
نهتم بمشاريع القوانين ذات الطابع
الاقتصادي لكي
تدور العزل الاقتصاديه نحو نحو
الناحيه الايجابيه وعندما يعني تدور العجل
الاقتصاديه نحو الناحيه الايجابيه سيكون
لها تاثير على المسار الاجتماعي
سقف زمني لاقرار مثل هذه التشريعات
الجديده التي يمكن ان يشعر بها المواطن
التونسي
نحن يعني في الدستور 25 جويليه 2022
صلاحيه تشريعيه
يعني تاتينا مشاريع القوانين من
من الوظيفه التنفيذيه عن طريق السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه او من خلال مبادرات يقوم بها
النواب يعني مبادرات نتاع مقترحات قوانين
يعني
وننتظر يعني هذه المشاريع التي سندرسها
وكذلك
حسب علمي هناك يعني العديد من النواب
الذين هم بسد اعداد مقترحات قوانين وسيتم
يعني عرضه على المجلس لمناقشتها والتصديق
عليها ان رؤوف ذلك انها تمثل يعني
يعني ناحيه ايجابيه بالنسبه للتشريعات
التي هي تسود البلاد وتسود الحياه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه
تاكد لي مره اخرى سعادتك هل تجاوزنا مرحله
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه للرئيس في تونس
الان
منذ يوم
يعني وقع تجاوز الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
واحيله الصلاحيه التشريعيه الى المجلس
التشريعي
ودليل على ذلك انه منذ يوم 16 مارس
لم يصدر اي مرسوم عن رئيس الجمهوريه لان
صلاحيه التشريعيه التي
يعني احيلت له بمقتضى امر 22 سبتمبر 21
انتهت يوم 16 مارس 23 طيب لكن هناك من ما
زال يستخدم عباره برلمان شرعي فيما يعد
انه عدم اعتراف بسلطه البرلمان الجديد ولا
بالعمليه الانتخابيه وكانه تمهيد
للسيناريو اللي حدث في ليبيا اللي بتتنازع
فيه الشرعيات اولا هل هذا يجد صداه لدى
التونسيين
والحمد لله يعني حافظنا على حريه التعبير
وحريه الاجتماع وحريه الاحتجاج
وكل يعني جهه سياسيه سواء يعني منظمه وحزب
يستطيعون العمل يعني بكل حريه في البلاد
ودليل على ذلك ان الاعلام يعني حر وكذلك
هناك يعني مظاهرات واحتجاجات
وسمح لها
بالتواجد
وبظهور الاعلامي وبالتالي يعني من له هذا
الراي بطبيعه الحال هو حر في
[موسيقى]
لكن ما يلاحظ ان هؤلاء لم يجدوا التجاوب
الشعبي الكافي بل على العكس من ذلك لا
زالت يعني
مسجد المصداقيه
واضحه بالنسبه لمسائل 25 جويليه والتي
تدابير 25 جويليه يوم الثلاثاء من اجراءات
دليل على ذلك انها يعني الشعب ينتظر
اصلاحات حقيقيه وقد سئم السوره النمطيه
للبرلمان السابق وبالتالي فهو ينتظر انه
هذا البرلمان يحقق له طموحاته ويحقق له
اماله ويحقق له اماله
[موسيقى]
بالحديث عن الاصلاحات الحقيقيه التي
يريدها المواطن التونسي ما هي اولويات
البرلمان الحالي
بالنسبه لينا يعني هناك يعني بالنسبه
للوضع في تونس هناك تراكمات حدثت يعني ما
قبل
اربعه 2011 وخاصه في العشريه الاخيره
يعني شهدت البلاد يعني عده ازمات وعدت
تقلبات سئيمها الشعب التونسي وبالتالي
فما ينتظره الشعب التونسي هو استقرار
الحياه السياسيه
ونمو المسار الاقتصادي واستقرار الحياه
الاجتماعيه وبالتالي
فان على الوظيفه التنفيذيه وكذلك البرلمان
الاهتمام بكل ما من شانه ان يصلح
عديد من القطاعات مثل يعني
تعليم مثل الصحه العموميه مثل النقل مثل
القضاء يعني على البيروقراطيه الاداريه
مثل يعني الاهتمام بالنواحي الاقتصاديه بث
الطمانينه لدى افراد الشعب التونسي وانه
بخلاصه القول انه في الماضي
استشرت يعني ثقافه الياس في البلاد واليوم
على البرلمان الحالي وكذلك الوظيفه
التنفيذيه العمل على استبدال ثقافه الياس
بثقافه الامل لا اكثر ولا اقل يعني كل
واحده مما ذكرت سعادتك بحاجه الى وقت طويل
من اجل تحقيقها على الاقل نبدا بالخطوه
الاولى لكن كما تقولون في تونس عدم
التنصيص على مفهوم المعارضه داخل البرلمان
في النظام الداخلي للبرلمان في الحقيقه
يبدو امر غير مالوف
هل هذا يعني ان هناك مواله فقط في هذا
البرلمان ولا في معارضه
لا لا غير صحيح اولا بالذات نعرف طبيعه
يعني الانتخابات التي
تمت ويعني
وقع بمجيبها انتخاب نواب البرلمان لاول
مره في تونس تطبق يعني
الانتخابات على اساس دوائر فرديه بنظام
الدورتين واغلب النواب هم نواب مستقلون
على الاحزاب يعني ما عدا حزبين شارك في
الانتخابات لكن لو نظرنا الى عدد النواب
لا وجدنا ان النواب المستقلين
يمثلون الاغلبيه
يعني الواضحه والاغلبيه المطلقه وبالتالي
في البرلمانات السابقه كانت هناك احزاب
تترشح هناك احزاب يعني حزب او مجموعه من
الاحزاب يفوزون بالاغلبيه ومن لا يفوز
بالاغلبيه يعني ينتقل للمعارضه بحيث ان
الحزب الذي يفوز بالاغلبيه يكون الحكومه
والحزب الذي لم يفوز بالاغلبيه ينتمي
المعارضه الان يعني الناب هو مستقل
وبالتالي هو اصبح اكثر استقلاليه من
نظم البرلمانيه سابقه بالنسبه لهذه العهده
النيابيه بدليل وانه النائب حر في التصويت
على القوانين اما مع قوانين او ضد قوانين
ومع ذلك
لا يعتبر من
المعارضه اذا ما سوت ضد قانون ولا يعتبر
من الموالاه اذا سوت مع قانون وبالتالي
حافظنا على استقلاليه الناب وعلى دوره
الحقيقي في التعبير على راي في مختلف
القوانين ودليل على ذلك انه في المستقبل
سيقع التصويت مع قوانين وسيقع التصوير ضد
قوانين ويبقى الناب في نفس الوضعيه لا
يعتبر لام المعارضه ولا
ترى بان هذا النموذج للبرلمان افضل من
البرلمان الحزبي اللي بيتشكل فعلا من
اغلبيه تحكم ومعارضه تراقب طريقه الحكم
اقصد الحكومه المجال التنفيذي يعني
نحن نقول وان لكل بلد ظروفه ولكل دوله
خصائصها ولكل مجتمع بطبيعه الحال يعني
وضعيته الخاصه ونحن الان نمر بمرحله يعني
جديده هذه المرحله خرجنا من الحكم الفردي
بعد
14 جانفي 2011 انتقلنا الى
نظام
رئاسي معدل ونظام برلماني معدل هذا النظام
لم ينجح في قرار يعني مسار سياسي مستقر
بدليل وانه
الاحزاب التي شاركت في الحكم تقول صحيح
اننا شاركنا في الحكم ولكن لا نتحمل يعني
مسؤوليه الفشل لانه لم تكن لنا الكلمه
الاخيره في الحكم
بطبيعه الحال ما هو مطلوب هو ان من يتحمل
المسؤوليه المسؤوليه الحكم يجب علي ان
يتحمل مسؤوليه النجاح ومسؤوليه الفشل
ولذلك
ادى الامر الى اتخاذ تدابير 25 جويليه
واختيار نظام حسب الدستور
الحالي يعني بنظام رئاسي يكون فيه رئيس
الوظيفه التنفيذيه مسؤوله عن النجاح هو
مسؤول على الفشل ويحاسب على النجاح كما
يحاسب على الفشل
المجلس التشريعي يقوم بصلاحياته سواء يعني
في التشريعه وذلك من خلال نظاره في مشاريع
القوانين التي تقدمها الوظيفه التنفيذيه
او من خلال مقترحات القوانين التي يقدمها
النواب وكذلك دوره الرقابي في عمل الحكومه
ويتمثل الدور الرقابي في عمل الحكومه في
امكانيه توجيه اسئله الى الحكومه في خصوص
مواضيع معينه في امكانيه توجيه استجوابات
لاعضاء الحكومه او لرئيسه الحكومه في
مواضيع معينه وله كذلك
بمعيه مجلس الاقليم الذي سيبعث في القريب
العاجل امكانيه لاي اعداد لايحه لهم ضد
الحكومه وفي سوره المصادقه عليها فما
يترتب عنها سياسيا هو ان رئيس الدوله اما
ان يغير الحكومه او انه يقوم بحل البرلمان
وعند ذلك ترجع الكلمه للشعب في اختيار من
يمثله
واضح سيد ابراهيم بودربال ارجو ان تتفضل
بالبقاء معنا سنذهب الى فاصل قصير نعود
بعده للمتابعه حوارنا
[موسيقى]
الخطه هو العمل التشريعي جاد في استعاده
الثقه عندما يلاحظ الشعب وان البرلمان
يعني يقوم بصلاحياته على احسن وجه وما
يتوافق مع الاراده الشعبيه عند ذلك سوف
نسترد ثقه الشعب في المؤسسه البرلمانيه
فبنعتقد انه في ايه انتخابات قادمه اذا
عادت ثقه الشعب في البرلمان سنشهد نسب
اكبر تذهب للتصويت اكثر من 11 او 15%
لا اكيد هو ربما بعض الاحزاب التي قاطعت
الانتخابات الفارطه هي نادمه اليوم لانها
لم تشارك في الانتخابات واعتقد وانها سوف
يعني
تقوم باستخلاص العبره من ذلك
واكيد انه في بالنسبه للانتخابات المقبله
سوف تشارك في الانتخابات لكن الا تعتقد
بان اي خطه لاعاده الثقه او بهذا الصدد قد
يكون لها مفعول عكسي مقارنه بالبرلمان
السابق هذا البرلمان قد يوصف بانه هادئ في
اعماله الا تخشون على صوره البرلمان التي
ربما تعيده للصوره النمطيه عن البرلمانات
التي برلمانات او نوعيه البرلمانات التي
يغيب فيها تنازع الافكار والرؤى وما يجلبه
ذلك من حماس كونه ما في احزاب ما في
معارضه وغيرها الكل مستقلون
او النسبه الاكبر طبعا
راوا بالنسبه للعمل البرلماني هو
الرائي والراي المعارض
ومقارعه الحجه بالحجه
ويعني تقديم الراي ونقيضه ثم استخلاص يعني
القرار الصحيح ولا يمكن ان يتحول البرلمان
الى حلبه صراع والى يعني
مسرح لتبادل
السب والشتم
والثلب لذلك
سوف تلاحظون بالنسبه لعمل البرلمان في
المستقبل والذي يبث في وسائل الاعلام يعني
مباشره في الجلسات وان العمل البرلماني
سيكون عمل صادق ونزيه وستكون
للنواب الحريه المطلقه في بدايه رايهم
وبطبيعه الحال هناك قناعات فكريه وهناك
قناعات سياسيه وكل سيدلو
يدلي بدلوه في الموضوع بكل حريه
[ضحك]
بهذه الطريقه اعتقد اننا سنسترد ثقه الشعب
في العمل البرلماني بس لكن
الايام بدور تشريعي وسياسي دون احزاب الا
يخشى
المرور او الانتقال من برلمان فوضى الكتل
الى برلمان الصوت الواحد هذا سؤال يعني
يسال كثيرا في الشارع التونسي
او الاحزاب لم تمنع من المشاركه في
الانتخابات او مشاركه في الحياه السياسيه
السياسيه بدليل انها الى يومنا الحاضر
لازلت تعقد اجتماعات ولا زالت يعني تعقد
ندواتها بكل حريه وهي حاضره في وسائل
الاعلام المختلفه وتشارك يعني في الحوارات
وبالتالي فهي هي التي اختارت يعني
الانعزال واختارت التقوقع وعدم مشاركه في
الانتخابات ولكن في المستقبل قلت انها
ربما ستستخلص يعني
العبره من موقفها السلبي وستشارك في
الحياه السياسيه في المستقبل وعلي اتحال
كل حزب ما هي دور الاحزاب دور الاحزاب هي
اولا تاثير مخاري فيها ثم تعبيتهم في
المواعيد الانتخابيه لانها على الاحزاب ان
تقوم بتاطير مخاريطها
وتهيئهم الانتخابات ثم لا تدعوهم للمشاركه
في الانتخابات في المواعيد المستقبليه
وعليه اتحال لا يوجد قانون تونس يمنع يعني
نشرت الاحزاب لكن يعني قد يرى البعض انه
ربما السبب الاساسي اللي يكون في اللي كان
في فوضى البرلمان السابق كان استخدام ورقه
الكتل لتسيير المجلس وفرد سياسات حرق فرض
سياسات الاحزاب محدده حركه النهضه مثلا
وفرض هذه السياسات على المشهد العام
للبلاد لماذا عدتم لنفس سياسه الكتل هل
هناك فرق
لا تواحه البرلمان الحالي فيه كتل عنا سته
كتل يعني
تكونت
وستنشط يعني داخل البرلمان ولكن يعني هناك
يعني بعض
الاحكام التي
اقرها الدستور وهو عدم
يعني
القضاء على السياحه الحزبيه لا يجوز
الانتقال من كتله الى كتله هو في الحقيقه
والواقع يعني المظاهر التي شاهدناها في
السابق في شراء ذمم يعني السماح بانتقال
النواب من حزب الى حزب وانتقال النواب من
كتله الى كتله هذايا اصبح يعني محاجر ومن
اختار الانضمام الى كتله عليه ان يبقى
بتلك الكتله واذا انسلخ عليها يبقى يعني
مستقل وغير منتمي ويواصل يعني
تحمل مسؤوليته البرلمانيه بتلك الصفه
موضوع الخلافات بين الكتل ما هي الاولويه
في حلها هل الجدل الحقوقي والايديولوجي ام
تغيير التشريعات كلها والتركيز فعلا على
الدوله الخدميه او الاداره والخدمات
للمواطنين اذا اردنا ان
نجعل المواطن التونسي يشعر بتغير في في
اداره الدوله
بالذات يعني الدستور التونسي يعني
وضح وان الدوله ثلاث وظائف في الوظيفه
التنفيذيه والوظيفه التشريعيه والوظيفه
القضائيه ومن يراقب هذه الوظائف هو الشعب
من خلال الاستفتاء والانتخابات وما الى
ذلك فمن هو مسؤول على سياسه الدوله هي
الوظيفه التنفيذيه رئيس الجمهوريه
والحكومه التي تساعده في ذلك ومن هو مسؤول
البرلمان من اجل المساعده والمساهمه في
التغيير
بطبيعه الحال قلنا وان الدستور سمح للنواب
وعددهم لا يقل على عشره يعني يقوموا
بمبادره لتقديم مقترح قانون وهذا المقترح
يعني يقع دراسته وفي سوره المصادقه عليه
يصبح يعني قانون سري مفعول
وكنت اسلفت القول وانه هناك العديد من
النواب الذين يفكرون في اعداد مشاريع
قوانين وفي اعداد يعني مقترحات قوانين
سيقع عرضها بصوره نظاميه على اللجان ذات
العلاقه ثم عرضه على الجلسه العامه
للمصادقه عليها
[موسيقى]
طيب سيد ابراهيم في بحثنا عن كهول معتاد
في البعد الاخر
قيل كثيرا عنك او عرف عنك بانك رمز
للاستقلاليه والحياد فيما كتب لكن الصوره
الان بشانك تبدو مختلفه يصر معارضوا هذا
البرلمان على تقديمك على خلاف صوره الرجل
النزيه التي اظهرتها عندما قلت منظمات
وطنيه كيف تنظرون لهذا
اولا لو بدات لازلت على تلك الصوره
تقدمت بوصف مستقل ولا زلت يعني
اسر على الاستقلاليه
يعني بالنسبه دي كموقف سواء عندما كنت في
عماده المحامين او الى الان يعني
مبادره 25 جويليا لان
رئيس الدوله انذاك والى الان يعني
اعلن محاربه الفساد
وبلادنا استشر فيها الفساد واصبح ينخر كل
المفاصل الدوله ولذلك لا يمكن انقاذ هذه
البلاد الا بالقضاء على الفساد وما دام
يعني رئيس الدوله ينتحي هذا النحو
ويعلن يعني الحرب لها هواده على الفساد
فانا اساندهم مسانده مطلقه وهذا لا يمس من
استقلاليه بل بالعكس هو يعني
برهان على اني مستقل في الافكار وعندما
يتراجع عن هذا الدور لكل حادث حديث
ه الكثيرون
عنك وخاصه مشاهدنا العربي الذي هو ليس
بالضروره ان يكون تونسي فقط انك كنت عضو
بالمجلس التاسيسي اللي كتب دستور عام 2014
وكنت تتميز بهديك الفتره بالحياد بين
مختلف مكونات المجتمع وايضا التشكيلات
السياسيه وقتها
ما الذي حدث لتغير رايك بشان ذلك الدستور
اولا لم اكن اعوذ بالمستاسيسي بل كنت عضو
يعني
اللجنه لجنه تحقيق هدف الثوره والاصلاح
السياسي والانتقال الديمقراطي اللجنه التي
وقع بعثها قبل المجلس التاسيسي وهي التي
بعملها انتج المجلس المجلس التاسيسي علي
اتحال فعلا في السابق كنت يعني
ربما
مناسب لفكره النظام البرلماني الحقيقي لا
البرلمانات المزيفه يعني برلمان معدل
ورئاسي معدل ولكن الوضع بعد التجربه
والوضع الذي مررنا به في بلادنا طيله
العشر سنوات الاخيره حتى ما وانه لا بد من
ان يكون هناك مسؤول في الوظيفه التنفيذيه
ويعني به رئيس الدوله والحكومه
على نجاح السياسه سياسه
سياسه الوظيفه التنفيذيه او كذلك مسؤولين
على الفشل وبالتالي فان الدستور الذي وقع
قراره يوميا 22 فعلا اصبحت يعني الوظيفه
التنفيذيه مسؤوله عن كل نتائج الحكم سواء
كانت ايجابيه او سلبيه وبالتالي
فان موقفي لم يتغير
وبتبيعه الحال يعني الاجتهادات السياسيه
تاخذ بعين الاعتبار ضررت الشعبي ودرجه
التطور يعني الفكري للشعب وفي الهاتف
المرحله يحتاج الشعب التونسي الى توضيح
المواقف والى الاهتمام باولويات هامه من
جملتها يعني استقرار المسار السياسي
وتنميه المسار الاقتصادي واصلاح الوضع
الاجتماعي ثم اكثر من ذلك اننا يعني نحن
امام حرب حقيقيه
قصد القضاء على الفساد الذي استشر في كامل
مفاصل البلاد وباذن الله سننتصر في
النهايه ونحقق ما يتمناه الشعب التونسي
سيد ابراهيم بودرباله مره اخرى ارجوك ان
تتفضل البقاء معنا سنذهب الى فاصل قصير
ثامن ونعود بعده لمتابعه حوارنا ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم معنا مشاهدينا الكرام ومره اخرى
ارحب بسعاده ابراهيم بودرباله رئيس
البرلمان التونسي
ودعني اسالك عن
استمرار منظمات من بينها الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل
ونقابه المحامين في الترويج لمبادره ترمي
الى اطلاق حوار وطني وهذا هدف يبدو انه
صعب المنال في ظل عدم تجاوب الرئيس معها
ما موقفكم من هذه المبادره
المبادره هذه هي اولا تعبر على فقط على
جزء من طموحات طموحات الشعبيه لانه اتحاد
العام التونسي شغل
وهيئه المحامين ورابطه التونسيه الدفاع
حقوق الانسان وكذلك يعني
المنظمه يعني الحقوق الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه هي تمثل جزء من طموحات الشعب
التونسي
تمثله ايضا الاتحاد التونسي للصناعه
والتجاره الاتحاد الفلاحين الاتحاد
التونسي للمراه وجوزه كبير مجتمع المدني
هذا فضلا على ان اللي كان لكي تكون مبادره
يعني منسجمه ومقبوله يجب ان تمثل يعني
طموحات الشعب التونسي بمختلف مكوناته
وكذلك كرهات الدوله التي تمثلها الحكومه
لان يعني الدوله التونسيه التزامات مع
المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه وكذلك التزامات
ثنائيه
والتزامات اقليميه وبالتالي لكي تكون هناك
مبادره مقبوله يجب مع كل هذه الاطراف اما
يعني تقديم مبادره من طرف اربعه منظمات
يعني تمثل جزء من يعني مكونات المجتمع لا
يمكن ان ترتقي الى مبادره يعني جديه يمكن
اجتمع حولها كافه الاطراف الفاعلين في
البلاد التونسيه ولذلك لماذا لا تاخذ هذه
المبادره ويتم ويتم تعزيزها واضافه اشياء
عليها او فتح خطوط اخرى مع الاخرين والبدء
في تطبيقها يعني لماذا
يبدو كانها مبادره مبادره ناقصه
اعلى موجودين في مجلس النواب ومستعدين
للحوار مع كل الاطراف التي تريد ذلك
وبالتالي يعني
هذه المنظمات ارادت فعلا تقديم عرض جدي
للحلول يعني تجمع كامل مكونات الشعب
التونسي فضلا على
الوظيفه التنفيذيه التي هي مسؤوليه مسؤوله
على سياسه الحكومه نحن مستعدون لذلك وما
عليهم الا ان يقدموا طلب في الغرض يعني
انتم عندكم تحفظات على هذه المبادره من
مواقفكم
الخاصه بكم لكن البعض يرى بانه بانها
لانها تتماهى مع موقف الرئيس هل يمكنكم في
لحظه ما لاختلاف مع الرئيس ودعم هذه
المبادره
ما انا قلت لك يعني المبادره هذه هي
منقوصه ولا يمكن انا ان ترتقي الى حل يقبل
من طرف كل مكونات يعني
البلاد التونسيه سواء يعني طموحات المجتمع
او الكريات الدوله وبالتالي اقول وان كل
المبادرات وكل المقترحات مستعدين لقبوله
ودراستها بشرط يعني ان يعبر عن ذلك صراحه
لا اكثر ولا
هناك اسئله الحقيقه حول الموعد الانتخابي
المقبل ونحن نعلم ان ولايه الرئيس قيس
سعيد تنتهي في اكتوبر من عام 2012 كما
اوضحت الهيئه المستقله للانتخابات في هذه
الاثناء نرى اصوات متعاليه من معارضي
الرئيس والبرلمان تؤكد ان تلك الانتخابات
لن تجري ما الذي تملكونه من معطيات
ومعلومات عن هذا الملف
معرفه عن السيد الرئيس هو انه استاذ قانون
الدستوري
ويحترم القانون ويحترم الاجل وكل المواعيد
التي اعلن على في السابق احترم اجلها ولا
ارى موجب لعدم احترام الاجل الانتخابات في
المستقبل واعتقد وانه سيكون دائما على
وعده في احترام هذه الاجيال الانتخابيه
ماذا عن المحكمه الدستوريه والجدل القائم
بشانها
الدستوريه مساله بسيطه جدا سوف يعرض
القانون الاساسي المنظم للمحكمه الدستوريه
على المجلس التشريعي
وسيكون من اولويات العمل التشريعي عندما
يقع عرض هذا القانون وعند المصادقه عليه
سنه تلتئم المحكمه الدستوريه لاننا مكونات
المحكمه الدستوريه نظمها الدستور وهي
تتكون من الاغذيه الثلاث القضاء العادي
والقضاء الاداري والقضاء المالي وعن كل
قضايا يعني هناك ثلاثه قضاه برتبه رؤساء
دوائر
لدى محكمه التعقيب يعني سرق لدى محكمه
النقد او البراما او محكمه التمييز
وبالتالي تقريبا الاشخاص الان معروفين
ننتظر فقط يعني
النظر في القانون الاساسي الذي سيعرض في
القريب العاجل على مجلس النواب
بس ياسين البارزين على غرار رئيس حركه
النهضه راشد الغنوشي والامين العام للحزب
الجمهوري عصام الشابي
القياديين بجبهه الخلاص المعارضه ما رايك
في هذه العمليه عمليه ايقافه
اولا التتبعات القضائيه التي تمت
ضدهم لم تكن بسبب انتماء اتهم الحزبيه او
بسبب ارايم او مواقفهم هي تمت يعني بسبب
افعال
نص عليه القانون الجزائري وعلي اتحال من
الناحيه القانونيه وبوصف عميد المحامين
اقول وان كل انسان بيري الى ان تثبت
ادانته خلال محاكمه تضمن الرهوف فيها حقوق
الدفاع وما دامت القضيه او القضايا امام
التحقيق
فهناك مبدا وهو وجوب احترام سريه التحقيق
واترك المساله للقضاء ليكون كلمته في
الموضوع هل هناك ما يثبت ان التحقيقات تتم
على افعال وليست على افكار
الحال يعني تحقيقات يعني كل
يعني شخص محالمه من التحقيق له لجنه دفاع
وله كم هائل من المحامين بالساده المحامين
الذين
يساندونه وينظرون على امام هذه الدواء
وبطبيعه الحال يعني حتى القرارات التي
يتخذها الحاكم التحقيق او قضاه التحقيق
ممكن تعن فيها امام المحكمه الاعلى درجه
وكذلك ربما حتى المحكمه الدرجه هي تحت
رقابه محكمه التعقيب وبالتالي اعتقد ان
الضمانات القانونيه متوفره
والمفيد وانه عندما يقع عرض المحكمه
القضيه امام القضاء في سوره قرار التتبع
ستكون
المحاكمه علنيه وسيدلي كل طرف يعني بدلوه
سواء النيابه العموميه باعتبارها مسؤوله
عن الادعاء او المحامون هم يسولون على
الدفاع
الكلمه هي للمحكمه التي يجب علي ان تتحمل
مسؤوليتها كامله في اصدار احكاما عادله
من متابعتنا للاوضاع في تونس او في رد فعل
لشارع التونسي على بعض القضايا هل يمكننا
ان نقول انه عزف التونسيون عن الدفاع عن
الملفات الحقيقيه ولا هو عزوف عن الدفاع
عن منظومه محدده بدليل انه التونسيين
تعاطفوا بشكل منقطع النظير على قضايا
الشباب غير المسيس مقابل فشل منظومه ما
قبل 25 مليون يوليو في تجميع الدعم من
الشارع التونسي
[موسيقى]
يعني القيام بعمل سياسي عليه ان
يلتحم بطبقات الشعبيه والاحزاب تقوم
بتاطير المجتمع كما يجب ان لا يقتصر عملهم
على النخبه وبالتالي يعني عند ذلك سيكون
لهم حضور في المجتمع وتاثير في الانتخابات
في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
الرئيس قيس سعيد وايضا جزء من البرلمان
بتهمه المعارضه بالاستنجاد بالخارج ما
الدليل على انه بيستنجدوا بالخارج اليست
هذه حجه
لاحاله من لا نريد المشاركه معهم
على الى الخلف
وحجه مستخدمه كثيرا
نحن يعني نرى يوميا ان العديد
يلتجئون الى يعني الجهات الاجنبيه
للاستقوابها وبالرغم من ذلك يتمتعون بكل
الحريه في بلادنا
ولم تقع متابعتهم قضائيا من اجل ذلك ولكن
سياسيا هذا يا شيء ثابت انهم يستنجدون
بمنظمات اجنبيه قصد التاثير على الوظيفه
التنفيذيه وعلى
سلطه القرار في تونس
واعتقد وان من اوقد الاولويات بالنسبه
لينا هو دفاعا استقلاليه قرارنا سيادي
وبالتالي هذا المسعى الذي
اتبعوه سوف لن يجديهم نفعا بل بالعكس
عليهم ان يبتعدوا
يعلموا كل العلم وان المشاكلنا تحل داخليا
بين افراد الشعب التونسي ما رايك
بردود الفعل الخارجيه حول الوضع في تونس
هناك ردود اعتقد انها ناتجه على عدم درايه
بحقيقه الامور في البلاد وناتجه عن
الدعايه المضاده وربما عن شبكه العلاقات
التي يتمتع بها كل من يعارض هذا التوجه
الجديد في البلاد وعليه اتحال يعني نحن
باتصال بكل من يريد معرفه الحقيقه في
بلادنا واستقبالهم
واتلاحهم على حقيقه الاوضاع واكيد ان بعد
ما يطلعون حقيقه الاوضاع سيغيرون مواقفهم
ودليل على ذلك هو ان العديد ممن اتخذ
قرارات المواقف سلبيه في السابق يعني
راجعوا مواقفهم بل بالعكس يعني عبروا عن
استعدادهم لمواصله يعني دعم دعم المسيره
السياسيه في بلادنا ودعم الاقتصاد في
تونس
تعتقد ان هناك مشكله في نقل الصوره
الحقيقيه لما يحدث في تونس للخارج من
يتحمل
مسؤوليتها هل بسبب ارتباط اطراف من
المعارضه مثلا من ابرزها حركه النحضه وهذا
ليس سرا ارتباطها تاريخيا باعلام لندن ثم
ايضا معارضه لها ارتباطات تاريخيه ايضا
باوساط فرنسيه لماذا ليس لديكم قدره على
اقناع عموم التونسيين العاديين غير
المسيسين في الوقت اللي ببدو انه هناك عجز
او فشل في نقل حقيقه الجدل القائم في تونس
للخارج
يعني هديه يعني شبكات عالميه اصبحت يعني
مسيطره على الاعلام في العالم واصبحت ما
يسمى بصناعه الراي العام
في مختلف البلدان اكيد انه لابد يعني من
اعداد استراتيجيه اعلاميه قادره على اعطاء
الصوره الحقيقيه بالنسبه للبلاد
ونستطيع القول واننا نجحنا وبدانا يعني
الخطوات الاولى في هذه الطريق وهو اعداد
الاستراتيجيه الاعلاميه واكيد اننا بهاته
الاستراتيجيه الجديده نجحنا في تغيير
الصوره النمطيه التي وقع الدعايه
التشويقها ضد بلادنا
سوف نحاول في المستقبل الدعم هذا التوجه
واعطاء السر الحقيقيه للوضع في تونس سيد
ابراهيم بودرباله رئيس البرلمان التونسيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على المشاركه معنا في هذه
الحلقه من البعد الاخر الف شكر والى هنا
تنتهي حلقه اليوم من البعد الاخر يمكنكم
دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقاتنا على العربيه
بودكاست ومشاهدتها على شاهد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]